well this is somewhat uh instructive and
i'm i feel a little more confident now
about my singing because and what can i
do to help my speaking voice do you
think my speaking voice could be pitched
differently is there any exercise i
could do no i wouldn't change a thing in
fact um whenever you whenever i consider
people who talk for a living
um now the extreme would be someone like
an nba coach who's screaming at
screaming at the players on on court in
a huge a tremendously loud environment
and you know you hear like tom thibodeau
who's like at a press conference he's
like ah yeah there's that and he's lost
his voice he's blown it out yeah yeah
and so anyone who used their voice
professionally if they and as you've
shown in three uh decades of doing this
your voice is never i mean has it ever
gone out have you ever had to cancel a
show i've had problems i've had problems
with my voice uh in the past just from
screaming at assistance and interns
um
i only uh and never at anyone who's uh
at my level i always punch down you know
so
i just like i like to lose it at people
who um have no control over me there's
no way they can
right david yeah no that's very accurate
dave does this sound familiar to you
where is my green tea that's what's
happening what happened ten minutes
before we got on here
i'll kill you yep that's it well you
don't have to worry about causing him to
have early labor like sona perhaps
that's true
yeah no i've had uh when i've played
larger venues i've had issues with my
throat if i get over-tired um
but then i have oh i've learned you've
got to do exercises and you've got to
drink you know special broths what
you've done works so i wouldn't change a
thing honestly kyle is it bad form to
ask uh an opera singer like yourself to
sing opera for us yeah can you give us a
demonstration
i i anticipated this how about you do
you do something and then i'll do
something okay so i'm going to take off
my headphones so i can hear myself
better and i'm going to guess on the
pitch of a very popular song you might
know it's from carmen
and i've done i've performed the role of
escamillo the bullfighter and maybe 175
performances of that
um so let's see um
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh my god
between a real opera star who knows what
he's doing and a jackass and it goes
something like this
wow that's not yeah the pitch is pretty
good i mean you see the words make it
sound like you're having a stroke but
the pitch
that was me and i don't know what i just
said uh
i think there's a couple of real words
in there accidentally i think i sang
about a futon